o sol surgiu mais um vídeo e hoje ensina
como fazer piquenique que fez o cartão e
muitas outras coisas que quase certeza
que vocês vão ter em casa e para
controlar as carrinhas envolve um novo
comando que é esse aqui que deve ser o
mais fácil todos que eu vou ensinar até
agora no canal
quando você quer me dar basta vocês irão
funcionar em contraste a bola e ainda
porque ele vai dar pra frente sendo os
leves mas vocês não tiverem leve podem
sempre irá de alguma coisa eletrônica
que foi avariada visava encostas e
principalmente como leve e depois basta
você ajudar é essa o tempo aqui no
botafogo e não fazer votos porque estou
em tempo os próximos dias mas quando eu
voltar eu vou tentar falar no próximo de
receita pessoal - que não deixará também
o estande de processos mentais que o
gosto de saber que vocês querem que eu
faço aqui no canal
então vote
[Música]
o tempo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
em seguida
o
o bastante
[Música]
o
eu
[Música]
boca
o
[Música]
o bertin
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o
não quero estar
[Música]
o momento
o músico
[Música]
i
o bumbum o vovô
[Música]
o gol
to
[Música]
[Aplausos]
engrossou o gansinho espero que vocês
tenham gostado deste projecto tiver
alguma sugestão é só deixar os
comentários que eu estou tentando fazer
o que vocês pedem mais obrigado pelo
vosso apoio e até a próxima
que tal